c'est que sédentaires parce que ça
c'était on a lille autres préposés
proposition de laurent berger il y a le
sénat la semaine dernière edouard
philippe
sur le plateau de tf1 demandé à la haute
assemblée de s'aligner sur le régime
général et la porte parole de la
république en marche a enfoncé le clou
ce matin mais je pense aussi que le
sénat doit être beaucoup plus proche
non seulement de ces grands électeurs
mais aussi des français et pour être
proche des français il faut à un moment
à être plus transparent sur la manière
avec laquelle l'argent public peut être
utilisée est aussi sur le régime de raï
a aucune raison que le sénat vote demain
une réforme des retraites qui fera qu'un
moyen certains français qui feront des
efforts dans cette réforme et que lui
sont exonère alors l'idée est en l'air
depuis quelques jours déjà et donc
gérard larcher avait fait cette réponse
sur le plateau culte nous allons
conduire la réforme nous mettre nous
même c'est pas question de nous battre
nous allons faire une proposition car
nous devons être là mais moan que les
français est ce que quand edouard
philippe hier dans son discours dit que
désormais avec cette réforme les élus
seront était comme tous les français en
citant les députés sont cités les
sénateurs d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
approuvez ce propos ils seront traités
comme tous les français mais aussi j'ai
noté hier le maintien des caisses
autonomes
le premier ministre se dit qu'il ferait
pas de hold up ou de ma basse sur les
crêtes dans les réserves
voilà les réserves et oui mais qui
appartiennent non pas l'état qui
appartiennent aux cotisants et à
l'institution carole les sénateurs
disent qu'on a voulu leur faire payer
leur refus de la réforme des
institutions les auditions de fer
benalla en un mot leur opposition
oui c'est possible c'est vrai 20 c'est
vrai que le sénat avait été assez en
pointe dans toutes ces affaires mais je
pense qu'au delà de ça il ya quelque
chose de beaucoup plus générale c'est
que macro nous dit pas que et la crise
des gilet jaune l'approuver 1
c'était la remise en cause quand même
des institutions de manière générale des
élus et surtout des grands élus on
entendait beaucoup parler des privilèges
des parlementaires etc et donc pour
faire passer une réforme pour tout le
monde
ils n'ont pas oublié évidemment de
mettre dans le lot les parlementaires et
les sénateurs qui sont une sorte de
symbole
bon maintenant c'est une chose de le
présenter c'en est une autre que ça
passe parce que le sénat est quand même
un peu maître chez lui aussi il ya que
lui qui on veut réformer mais d'un autre
côté alexis quand même langage ils sont
moins représentatifs que les députés et
pour lequel les régimes et moi je passe
sur je suis pas spécialiste de la
question mais je ne suis pas absolument
sûr de ça je pourquoi est-ce qu'on se
focalise il y cotisent deux fois plus
oui mais aussi à l'orias la nicotine y
cotisent y cotisent plus mais une finale
100 social mondialisation collectif
c'est à dire que puisqu'on a non pas qu
un salarié du privé va cotiser plus
puisque voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est
un droit qu'on les parlementaires que et
ont rejoint un peu la capitalisation
enfin ça me paraît un peu un dérivatif
que c'est sûr je suis tout à fait pour
comble le sénat passe la toise comme
tout le monde mais s'il le fait qu au
même rythme que les que les cheminots
c'est bon il ya un an comme l'ena pour
35 ans donc ça va je pense que l'archer
tranquille il peut dormir sur ses deux
oreilles
je passe je vous dis je pose la question
également pascal parce que il y a quand
même la question de remettre la question
la question qu'on pose sur twitter ses
fautes ils vont supprimer les avantages
du régime de retraite des sénateurs
et c'est oui 90 92 % donc c'est démago
mais ça si vous c'est démago mais ça
peut marcher mais là on discute
sérieusement faut arrêter cette
démagogie
faut arrêter cet antiparlementarisme qui
peu à peu et risque de nous coûter très
cher parce que le jour où on aura
complètement lessivé les représentants
qu'est ce qui restera il restera la
démocratie soit disant manifestantes et
la démocratie de la rue si on se prive
des représentants il faut arrêter vous
voyez bien qu'il y aille à un seul
contre-pouvoir dans le système
aujourd'hui c'est le sénat qui est de
droite
alors que tout le reste en effet
l'assemblée nationale l'exécutif bon là
c'est la république en marche donc il y
à des règlements de compte et on le voit
bien dans cette députée de la république
en marche qui règlent des comptes
vis-à-vis d'un sénat qui en plus de ça a
fait son travail de contre-pouvoir on
l'a vu sur la sphère benalla et on l'a
vu sur bien d'autres domaines
donc il y à un règlement de compte
politique et je crois que personne n'a à
gagner aussi bien du côté de l'assemblée
nationale que du sénat cette perpétuelle
chamailleries entre les deux chambres du
parlement
et puis quand vous regarder en détail
les cotisations des sénateurs sont
nettement plus importantes nettement
plus importante que celle des députés et
% contre 18 % que 2000 cadres équivalent
des cadres supérieurs ou équivalents
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose il faut pas croire que en tant
qu'employeur le sénat mais l'argent par
par les fenêtres ils cotisent nettement
moins en tant qu'employeur que l'état
vis-à-vis de ses fonctionnaires moitié
moins à moitié moins d'autre part
yannick est ce qui existe depuis 1905
qui est une caisse qui elle en effet
finances 60% des retraites parce que ça
a été bien gérée et parce qu'il ya une
capitalisation en effet au fur et à
mesure des années qui fournit 60% des
retraites quatrième élément les
sénateurs parts à 70 ans
donc ils partent à huit ans de plus que
la moyenne des français 62 ans donc les
pensions sont sur un temps nettement
plus brefs et d'autre part quand vous
regardez traduiront lequel tant de
livres il n'y a pas voyez pas ce qu'on
crie au scandale valeur par scandale si
vous voulez moi je veux bien qu'on me
démontre mais comme le démontre un conte
se contente pas d'un anti
parlementarisme j'allais dire de café du
commerce
1 et enfin quand on regarde les avancées
de 2003 de 2010 2014
à chaque fois le sénat les a accompagnés
et le président du sénat vient de dire
qu' il rentrera dans le système qui
savons c'est que le sénat rentrera le
moment venu il va pas rentrer avant
connaissait bien
la ccc habile quand même christophe pour
le gouvernement mais d'un autre côté ce
qui est vrai c'est que y'a rien de
scandaleux à ce qu'on m'aime sur le
principe on privilégie même des
serviteurs de l'état dans une démocratie
et que sont dès lors deux choses moi je
d'ailleurs pascal perrineau là est
vraiment prêt à être élu comme sénateur
car je trouve ça devrait être le cas
d'autre part je m'aperçois que
rhétoriquement c'est une histoire de
berger depuis le début j'ai pas osé vu
en parlent de leurs rangs puis
maintenant parle d'europe 1 4 à aurore
bergé et oui certainement et
certainement des arrière pensées
politiques
je pense que c'est un petit peu comme
vis-à-vis de la cfdt je pense qu'il
faudra qu'à un moment donné les
sénateurs je dirais lâche un peu de lest
pour montrer l'exemple
je parle pas de démagogie juste pour
montrer l'exemple
c'est à dire ce que nous dit baba
l'invention par le principe qu'il y ait
un régime universel des sénateurs de
montrer l'exemple à l'avant sans pour
autant s'en pour en tenant compte des
spécificités mais c'est le cas pour tous
pour les policiers il faut tenir compte
des spécificités de la brièveté du
mandat et et puis après tout du fait
qu'ils sont quand même censé travailler
on est en train d'inventer un régime
universel qui sera pas universel
puisqu'il aura le régime des policiers
des sénateurs des enseignants des aides
soignants des militaires et patati et
patata et qu'on est en train d'inventer
un système - qui ne sera pas à point
parce qu'un point qu'ils baissent pas
c'est pas un point faut pas se raconter
d'histoires le principe du point c'est
d'ajuster ses deux réalisé les clips
financiers donc si sam universel paix
universelle système à points pas points
mais bon mais c'est une très grande
réforme
décidément vous lisez peu de chance mais
encore une fois les choses étant ce
qu'elles sont et puis comme je suis à
gauche de la date de la table
aujourd'hui moi je pense que l'afer est
parti le point ne sera jamais touché ça
c'est un petit peu comme la wii nous
verrons mais ouais mais pourquoi les
gens se méfient parce qu'ils sentent
bien que ce que vous dites on leur dit
que le point bas sera pas et c'est comme
une campagne et le nombre de trimestres
il est fixé dans les reins de la
constitution le nombre de trimestre en
trimestre on la travaille non non ce que
je vais rière le fait qu'on puisse
retarder la durée l'argument dieu sur le
point qui peut changer je voudrais vu
leur thé franchement qui va travailler
plus mais plutôt que d'en raconter qu'on
va faire un poids qui baissera pas pour
le bc en catimini dans dix ans vous vous
dites vous même ce que redoutent les
gens mais on est comme vous le savez
comme vous savez je ne soutiens pas
forcément oui c'est ce que je vais dire
pas clair que dans cette affaire de
point mais on ne peut pas avoir assez
fait pour blesser on ne va pas faire
dans un pays où les sillons mais oui
dans un pays où les gens ont des
privilèges et vous quand même bien voir
les choses là là je parle comme
historien la révolution française ça va
aider l'abolition des privilèges chat
était leur redistribution faut quand
même qu'on le camp qu'on le voit une
fois pour toutes
donc ces privilèges comme vous savez les
gens parlent volontiers du privilège du
voisin d'avoir armand douleur mais à
tous les niveaux les sénateurs comme le
cheminot duk est dans un pays où les
français on en a parlé sur ce plateau
ont peu de connaissances économiques
d'accord et peu de connaissances
financières
je pense qu'il est très difficile de
parler vrai et je dis ça mais moi je
crois que bon voilà ce que le parlais
pas vrai le par les diesel ça donne
si on avait dit aux gens vous allez tous
travailler un peu plus progressivement
et ceux qui travaillent vraiment
beaucoup moins que les autres c'est à
dire les cheminots là vont travailler
davantage et au passage on va rémunérer
mieux les enseignants parce que c'est
pas bien ça ça fait pas forcément très
plaisir mais ça peut passer
surtout qu'en gros on lit que tout le
monde contre les régimes spéciaux c'est
comme ça que ça se passe
ça peut marcher mais là votre truc on
dire faire un point qui sera pas le cas
non mais le système audi refaire un
poids qui baissera pas mais bon mais
chacun sait bien qu'on va quand même le
bc pour dire la vérité je suis beaucoup
alors on va essayer de dire la vérité
sur un autre point
/
sur un autre point qui termine et aurait
quitté sur ça c'est le 23e jour de grève
à radio france il ya de nouvelles
perturbations encore ce matin sur les
antennes de france inter